CLAIRE HANNA WITH YOU AS T
THEODORE WHITECLOUD ON THE
BLUE LINE.
38-SAVE
ON THE WALL BY BROWN,CE.
DOWN LOW.OWN DOWN LOW, SPINS BY
>> Jon: SNAPS IT ON, LEHNER
ONE-STOP REBOUND IS THERE.
ONE-TIMER.
THAT IS BLOCKED, NORRIS DOWN LOW
AA
SHORT SIDE AND THEN NORRIS DOWN
NHL GAME AND THREAT. PERIOD
NUMBER TWO, BUT SANFORD ABLE TO.
WATSON PICKS IT A CHANGE OF
MINUTES IN THE SECOND PERIOD, I
THINK BOTH WANT T
NICE LITTLE PASS, TRIES TO GO
FOREHAND.
EN KNIGHTS.
>> Jon: THERE WAS AGHT OFF THE
AND IN THE YELLOW
PIETRANGELO AND HOLDENZOTTO WAN
BOUNCING PUCK, METE GETS LOST ON
T
ARMED FORCES APPRECIATION NIGHT,
MEN AND AVED
THIS IS HIS THIRD GOOD CHANCE
AND A NICE EPARATE SMITH
FROM WHAT W
HEART.
WIDE
LOW, RIGHT BACK TO PIETRANGELO.
GETS A GOOD ANGLE AND TOUCHES  .
ZUB...
MARCHESSAULT IS JUST GOING TO
THROW THIS IN TO THE W